our next panel competing with skills
winning with confidence many of you have
reached out to us about how to get a job
in areas where you don't yet have
experience you've learn new skills
you're now looking for the next job how
do you go about doing that the paradox
of getting a job when you can't get
hired without prior experience you see
this on resumes a lot you know five plus
years experience here three plus years
experience there how do you do that
that's actually really common in the new
modern hiring era with the changing of
jobs similarly how do you have
confidence to apply for these new roles
when you may not feel confident yet
about your experience our next panelist
discussed why and how confidence matters
explore the complex relationships
between skills and confidence and share
strategies for turning that to your
career advantage our panel moderator is
Kathleen Mulaney VP of careers at
Udacity Kathleen joined Udacity as one
of our first employees in 2011 she's a
frequent speaker at education and tech
conferences and prior to Udacity worked
as a data analyst on Google Maps where
she created tools to help improve team
processes and map data quality kathleen
is joined by our panelists
Aileen Lerner co-founder and CEO at
interviewing do Nika Rose VP of employer
branding and talent acquisition at
Bertelsmann Aubrey Blanche global head
of diversity and inclusion at a lace ian
and chapman snowden founder and CEO at
signal i/o please join me in welcoming
our panelists
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone thank you for joining our
panel as Clarissa introduced it we are
talking about competing with skills and
winning with confidence so a lot of
people in the room today have completed
a nano degree program or maybe you're in
a nano degree program today you're
gaining a ton of new skills and what do
you do next with them what we've what
we've learned and actually what what is
the wisdom of this panel and many others
is that it's not just the skills that
you have it's also the confidence it's
the way that you go forth and you
actually share those skills with the
world and so we're going to talk more
about that today and hopefully give you
some practical advice on how to increase
your confidence in many different
situations and I'm particularly excited
to have this diverse crowd of experts
because we have you know when I when I
was learning all of this myself first
hand I didn't know that there were
experts so it's nice that we can
actually pull together a panel of people
who are engineers who are psychologists
who have are working at companies who
are you know managing thousands of
people to actually help them you know
manage their own careers and and that's
who we have here with you today
so chop just to give people a little bit
more context where this expertise comes
from chap here is the founder of
traverse it's a smart research assistant
before that he was at dev bootcamp
running product and also creating
education products with Google he is
also a self-taught developer which I
think many of many of you in this room
can relate to Aileen is the co-founder
and CEO of interviewing Daioh which is a
blind interviewing platform and it's one
that also many of you probably have
practiced with she also for a brief
period ran hiring at Udacity so we're
grateful to have her back and something
you might know if we actually share
often her blog post about data in
recruiting where she shows that typos
actually often matter more than pedigree
and and many other insights Audrey
Blanche here is the head look at the
global head of diversity and inclusion
at Atlassian and who doesn't use
Atlassian
jeera confluence cello all of these we
use all of those at Udacity so and it's
a huge company that is may many of
people are remote actually and so
there's there's a ton of again like
insight here coming from a variety of
angles and last we have dr. Nico Rose
so Nico is our international contingent
coming to us from Germany where he's the
vice president of employer branding and
talent at bertelsmann which is Europe's
leading media company Bertelsmann and
Nico will maybe mention this later and
we'll say he'd say that bertelsmann is
the company behind many many companies
and products that you're familiar with
if you're not familiar with that name
itself
he's a proponent of positive psychology
hopefully he'll come up later today that
he is it has a doctorate but not in in
what he does here today and we have a
variety of career backgrounds here that
we'll be happy to share so thank you all
for joining us and thank you panel for
joining us we're gonna start off with a
question that I'd hoped that each of you
will answer because of the the varied
backgrounds that you have the common
thread is is really around technology
and also around empowerment empowering
people from broad backgrounds to
increase their their access and their
opportunity and that is really what
we're talking about here this lifelong
learning really needs that empowerment
and an access to opportunity for it to
really work so feeling confident versus
acting confidence what behaviors do
confident people have that we all can
adopt and we can start with you chap or
anybody who wants to wants to kick this
off you'd see the collective confidence
on the panel no confidence oh yeah I'll
start us off I think for the people I
admire who exude confidence I think both
act and and come come off as confident
it's a sort of consistent process of
mapping things that they don't
understand back to sort of some mental
model that they understand and I think
actually a person who's great at this is
Elon Musk classically trained as a
physicist
and so constantly sort of like when
doesn't understand something brings it
back to first principles of this
discipline that he understands which is
physics and that can sort of extrapolate
from there and so I think depending upon
what you've you know sort of call your
sort of innate mental model or mental
models I think a great thing is sort of
understand when encountering something
that you don't understand bring it back
to what you do and sort of work from
there yeah I would say the other thing
and this is something about confident
people that they know about other people
which is that even other confident
people don't know everything I think we
can tell ourselves these stories that
like oh that person knows everything I
have to you know talk about my skills in
a glass half empty way or I need to
caveat this and it turns out that you
don't need to do that even super
confident people don't know what they're
talking about sometimes and sort of it
right that's true like you on sometimes
doesn't know what he's talking about and
that's okay so I think holding that
allows you to approach you know to get
back to the piece where you are
confident but knowing that being out
there outside of your expertise it
doesn't mean you're not an expert at
something I'll add that um it's having a
bit of swagger because your worst fears
have come true so whether it's messing
up an interview or you know messing up
some kind of public speaking engagement
if it's happened and you've gotten
through it you don't have to worry about
it anymore
so part of confidence I think is is
failing a lot and and learning from
those failures but also realizing that
no matter how bad you thought it was
going to be it's not that bad
well you translate the German word for
confidence back into English it actually
means self trust so trusting yourself
and the question is when do you trust
somebody mostly when you know somebody
so I think that confidence comes from
finding out what your real strengths are
and you can do that by taking tests
online but I think also one important
way is just getting lots of feedback so
sometimes you know about your own
strengths but a lot of times their
strengths in you that you don't even see
yourself but other people can can tell
you that and bringing those real
strengths to an interview situation is
some
that's very strong authentic as opposed
to you know saying like oh I'm really
impatient that's where you get a lot I'm
not interviewing I don't know we're here
that I want to heal your real strength
if you know about that and bring that to
the interview that's something very very
strong and authentic so to to follow up
that one how do you actually grow your
confidence and anybody can take this now
I research right so in a former life
before I Randy and I I was actually an
academic researcher I studied military
strategy right so I'm highly qualified
for my job right but I think I think
that's it is for me researching two
things so trying to understand whatever
I want to know whether it's how to get a
job or how to run a global DNI
Department but then also researching
what other people don't know that's true
so I'm a big fan of anyone who puts out
like their resume of failures right I
tell this story when I try to get into
tech I sent out 130 job applications and
got three callbacks and so I think
that's it like whether it's talking to
people but understanding that your
failures are actually quite normal and
you the the success is the selection
bias
like it's all you see it's usually like
1% of the outcomes I think that can help
you realize that where you are in an
experience is actually quite normal if
not exceptional usually especially if
you're already sitting in this room so
level set with yourself yeah I'll
piggyback off of that so the company I
run called interviewing IO helps people
practice technical interviews and find
jobs in the process and we've amassed I
think something like 20,000 technical
interviews at this point it's a lot and
one of the rezoning themes we've seen
over and over again is that people are
not consistent in their performance and
even the best people fail quite often in
fact only about 20% of people are
consistent in how they perform and
everybody else is all over the place so
what ends up happening a lot of the time
is maybe you mess up an interview but
lift and you end up at over and then of
course lists recruiters are contacting
you immediately or vice versa
and this is just part of this industry
so fail
are very real but they're not an
aberration they're actually the norm and
I'm sure the supplies to non-technical
interviewing as well yeah I think first
you all have to acknowledge that
everybody is winging it all the time
we're totally winging it right now it's
part of the game you're winging it that
recruiter is winging it and that takes a
lot of the pressure out at the same time
I do believe in a lot of practice and
that's not opposites I do believe you
need practice to what what psychologists
call self-efficacy that's basically the
scientific term for for confidence and
one way to build this up is kind of
looking at your past successes which is
kind of no-brainer but then what do you
do when you are in a new situation
sometimes it helps just to to watch
other people succeed for example in an
online course and then a lot of practice
and you do practice not to bring your
practice to the interview it's not a
recruiters trip they don't want to hear
a pitch they want to hear a person so
you do practice to be confident and
winging it that's what I believe in it
would build on the concept of practice I
think often especially when you're
thinking about in the context of a
technical interview you can go to a
hacker rank or any of these sites and
sort of like see all of these different
sort of canned examples that you'll
probably be asked and I think often
times you can sort of get into this rut
of like one particular solution to a
problem I think a great way to enhance
your practice is also to teach and find
anybody it doesn't matter whether
they're technical or not but explain the
topic because oftentimes what you get
and especially to those who are
beginners they'll ask a question that
you've sort of attracted over a glossed
over you're like oh wait I've got a yes
now I've got to go back and incorporate
that into my answer so sort of adopting
both I like the learner and the teacher
role is incredibly helpful in getting
ready for any sort of like technical
interview yeah we actually see a lot of
our students do this with each other so
if you're a Udacity student 'day your
peers are a great audience for you to
practice teaching practice your
interviewing skills you know absolutely
take advantage of these opportunities
because the more that you know you know
today and the more that you're going to
be able to perform actually on the day
of in your interview
so again related because all of these
are how these topics are gonna be
related you know for all of us in the
tech industry so everybody in this room
and everybody probably online as well
technology is changing so rapidly we
just heard that in the last panel you
know all of these all of these changes
from you know digital surveying and in
in cities to you know self-driving cars
that technology is something that you
can't be an expert in because it's gonna
change tomorrow so if you can if you if
you know practice and knowledge is is
you know Billups you build confidence
how do you deal with this how do you
deal with you know a topic that's
changing continuously I think a
programming language has changed but
algorithms are forever
that a greeting-card should be I think
that the most important thing is to
understand how things work under the
hood chap talked earlier about being a
first principles thinker and I think
that that mentality is critical when
you're teaching yourself to program and
probably most most other disciplines as
well so I wouldn't beat yourself up
about the fact that by the time you
become an expert at something it's gonna
be completely obsolete the the journey
that you took to become the expert is
going to be applicable to any number of
things and hopefully the companies where
you interview are going to be
interviewing you on your engineering
aptitude if you are an engineer rather
than on trivia and if they're
interviewing you on trivia they're
probably doing it wrong yeah I would say
speaking from HR land even you know
Deloitte and McKenzie right now are
talking about the fact that the
half-life of skills it used to be 10
years now it's 5 I imagine only about
two and a half in the next decade and so
one of the things that like we added
lossy and look for but I think you
should understand to pull in one of your
great comments is actually knowing how
you learn and knowing how to do that
really well I think is the number one
job skill that anyone can have because I
can tell you like I work in diversity
like my job title is like an evil joke
it's like you literally can't ever be
good at it you can't know anything and
and so for me it
I know exactly once I have a target how
I learn I'm a reader I'm a visual person
I know how to go get the information I
need or have the ability and humility to
ask and if you can do that you can
become an expert in anything and that's
what your career is gonna require of you
for the next 10 20 years anyway and I
think saying something like that to a
hiring manager is totally within bounds
and I think you should write to say I'm
actually amazing at learning how to be
great at this I ramped up in this amount
of time I did a nano degree because I
thought I could do it while juggling all
of these other things isn't that amazing
people input I can I can verify you know
we've we've helped thousands of people
find find jobs at Udacity and employers
really do say this that like they're
nano degree and having something to talk
about that shows their grit and shows
how much they were self-motivated to to
grow their own skills while you know
having a family managing another job is
something that is is it really a skill
that's laudable it's a thing one thing
to cultivate in yourself is what Carol
Dweck from Stanford University called
growth mindset as opposed to a fixed
mindset fixed mindset is basically where
you're shut down you know you know
everything that you're already should
know and if you call him that mindset
you basically become afraid of learning
you become afraid of growing and we put
afraid of not knowing something and just
seeing yourself as a sa constant learner
and also actually finding a boss that
encourages you to to learn and grow and
and see the potential as opposed to
what's what's already there is something
that's very crucial and the truth is you
will never stop learning I learned
something new every week and there's
always some at least sometimes there's
some pain in growing that's that's part
of what you do and a little bit of
enjoying that pain of growth I think
it's something that we all should
cultivate and then you get the joy after
being gritty and you've grown and that
brings you new success and then comes a
next growth phase and that will continue
for
our lives and I encourage you to search
for that painting so the rest of the
panel to riff off of neko nature versus
nurture are people born with certain
attributes that make them better for
certain jobs do you agree or disagree is
it is it nature and/or nurture
that's a can of worms yeah 19 minutes
looks like yeah probably not gonna go
it's a combination of both is sort of
the cop-out answer I think but also the
answer I believe in I think it's you can
train yourself to think in many
different ways it's sort of a function
of how much time you have and what's the
what's the priority through it if it's a
exercise that's just theoretical then
that can be more difficult if it's a
place where you see sort of like future
utility or there's some application for
it I think that can be really helpful
and trained if you struggle with
algorithms for example because you don't
understand the math behind it like that
gives you a really concrete way to say
okay I don't need to know all of
discrete math I don't need to know all
of calculus I just need to know around
the specific universe so I think there's
there's a bit of it which is sometimes
it just comes intuitively and sometimes
you can come you can give yourself sort
of like a narrow enough application to
be able to learn the stuff that you that
you need to know yeah I agree I think
that we probably all lean certain ways
but I think that those natural leanings
are actually largely irrelevant right so
I think that we do have different
aptitudes but it's more about what we do
with them than anything right do we have
the opportunity to stretch and grow
because I can write I I can tell you I
have sort of a natural facility with
languages like I've always found
learning them pretty easy but like there
becomes a point where like Arabic is
just hard and so it doesn't matter that
like the first few vocabulary rubs I did
were easy and so we may all have
different ceilings where it gets hard
but the fact is it's actually not about
when it gets hard it's what we do when
it does so it's I back that question to
what I said in the beginning on the
importance of strength so one
way to find out what your real strengths
are is to look at stuff that you're
learning exceptionally fast so if you
start something if you started learning
an instrument if you start to code
and you have a peer group you find out
that you learn considerably faster than
everybody else that's a sure sign that
there's a lot of nature to be nurtured
right so if you find something like that
build on that and make the other things
irrelevant and there's some things where
nature is a little more important
there's something where nature is a
little more important at the end of the
day everybody of us has certain
strengths and finding that out at best
early in your life is really the path to
the constant growth and I think that
what matters most is whether you care
about the thing you're doing if you
don't have a natural predisposition for
it yeah you're gonna have to work harder
but if you enjoy the journey and you
really care about the thing it's not
gonna feel like pain I mean it will some
of the time because I don't know I
caffeine mentioned in my intro how I did
a study where I discovered that the
number of typos and grammatical errors
on people's resumes mattered more than
they went to school and where they
worked and I spent months of my life
after work sitting in bed and marking up
resumes and counting typos and you know
I ended up writing something that was
pretty cool about hiring that nobody
else had done before I didn't know that
would happen but I did it because I was
so frustrated with how companies were
hiring and I didn't care about counting
typos um and a lot of that the work
you're doing might be unglamorous but if
you're if you're into it or if you have
a chip on your shoulder like I did and
you feel a lot of rage and you want to
change change something about the status
quo it's not going to feel that bad so I
I would kind of encourage people to find
a thing that they care about and if you
really truly care about it that's gonna
give you an edge over people who are
naturally very very suited to that work
but don't have the same level of passion
very good answers um so for people who
don't have a traditional background it
this might be you know maybe a cheddar
chip on people's shoulders or or maybe
perhaps we have
no opportunities that that seemed
unachievable because we don't have the
cs degree from Stanford like like you
know other people how does one sell the
value of a non-traditional background to
an employer so every single person on
this panel myself included we all have
non-traditional backgrounds I I think
we're pretty successful I don't know I
think a lot of people in this room are
pretty successful but you know for you
your brother from your personal
experience or how you've coached others
what are the best ways for you to
present these these nonlinear career
paths and this this nonlinear background
to to an employer that's a good one so I
think it ought to start with what kind
of employers you're looking for in the
first place and there will be employers
out there that value that kind of
diversity and flexibility in your CV and
there would be other employees that kind
of don't value that and that's the first
thing what are you looking for for me it
was pretty easy I I joined Bertelsmann
seven years ago and I'm all of this or
started as a psychologist worked a
little bit in HR then I decided to get a
PhD in in something that I still don't
know anything about and it was horrible
self-employed on the way because I
didn't want to work on the PhD and then
I joined the consultancy work in CRM and
now I'm back in HR so there is no no lie
in whatsoever
but we're in a creative industry and
creativity turkey doesn't come from a
specific place it comes from connecting
different sources and and then something
something used created so it really
starts with first not being afraid to
show who you are but again look for
those places where where that is valued
and they are out there and that's my my
advice to you I think the the second
piece is you have to understand that
getting a job is a marketing exercise
and you need to be able to tell the
story authentically like it's not don't
do the thing where it's like what's your
weakness
factionist
right right but it's but so when but I
think presenting like asserting that
your non-traditional background is a
value-add first is crucial right because
then it's on the other person to
challenge that you're lying they won't
do that to give you context I started
college as a vocal performance major
graduate of his study at Middle Eastern
languages and journalism like have a PhD
in Poli Sci and worked in business
development before someone hired me to
run a global DNI Department right like
none of that makes sense right
someone was drunk it send offer I don't
think that's actually true but but what
I was able to say in that context was
actually I'm great at public speaking I
was trained as an opera singer I know
how to communicate with people across
cultures I picked up some really badass
research skills and so I didn't focus on
how I got the skill and I would offer
that to everyone we've all picked up
skills and what I notice also is that
people think that only skills they
developed while getting paid count and
that's not true
right so maybe you were running a major
global P&L function for McKinsey and so
you were managing multiple stakeholders
with time and financial constraints or
maybe you were just trying to get your
three kids to soccer practice ballet and
dinner on the table right and it's the
exact same skill that you've used and so
I think that something is you can always
find the value add in your experience
but you have to be an excellent
storyteller because the recruiters won't
connect the dots for you yeah so I think
that that's true
but I think even getting somebody to see
your story in the first place is very
difficult right I don't know how many of
you have applied to companies on their
careers website and just never heard
back I think of it as screaming into a
black hole
in fact I've worked at companies where
for months nobody would look at that
channel and people would just get
automatic rejections and then you think
somebody looked at who I was went
through everything I've done and made a
decision that I'm not suited for this
job and in reality nobody cares about
you nobody ever looked at it in the
first place so especially if you're a
non-traditional Kent
generally recruiters are
pattern-matching because they're busy
and I think there have been studies that
say that a recruiter looks at a resume
for something like six to ten seconds
before they make a decision and when
they're doing that they're going down
the list and looking for brand name
brand name brand name okay you've hit
the threshold of number of brand names
you're in you don't have the brand name
you're out that sucks it sucks a lot but
if you're non-traditional the reality is
you're gonna have to hustle and what
does that mean it means finding people
who work at that company that maybe
aren't in recruiting that are actually
doing the job that you want to do so
maybe it's reading their engineering
blog or reading the blogs of people who
work there in connecting with them based
on what they're writing about and saying
you did this really cool thing I'm
interested in that I know a little bit
about it here's what I've done can I get
your advice
one thing I've seen over and over is
that people here and I think people in
general responded very well when
somebody cares about something and they
talked about caring before so if you're
passionate and you show that passion
then people are gonna want to invest in
you because so few people care about
anything that when it's genuine it's
it's so refreshing so get on Quora get
on Hacker News read people's blogs find
those people find their emails reach out
to them and tell that story like Aubrey
said about what makes you unique and
connected to what they're doing
and make a genuine don't talk about
networking just you know talk about
something real I would like to add
something you have the right to edit
your CV and an interesting way and
there's different words for for the same
thing to say and different companies
want to hear different things and
there's nicer and and and less nice
words to give you an example I I worked
actually as a bouncer in a nightclub
when I was when I was a student which is
kind of similar to recruiting but that's
another thing and there are several
words for for that in Germany one is
chill scare that's really bad and then
there's a nicer one which actually comes
from France it's selective so and the
question is what what do you put in your
CV and and you have the right to edit
that in a nice way as long as it kind of
still portrays
the truth and I encourage you to do that
also tongue twister can anybody say
either I would build on what a mean said
I worked at a boot camp for a while
where we did sort of similar training to
what you just went through but in person
and you'd get students who would
graduate and were just so excited they
wanted to be a Google engineer they want
to be a Facebook engineer or whatever
it's sort of like the buzz company of
that moment was and one of the hardest
things that we had to sort of convince
them of is similar in the vein of like
shorten the distance between you and
that company right and so interact with
engineers that are there and remember
that you are interviewing them as much
as they are interviewing you because we
saw time and time again students get
really excited to get this offer from
this really cool startup and then two
months in they're like this sucks
like I don't enjoy the culture I'm not
working on what I wanted to work on so I
think as you sort of like shorten that
distance remember that like you're
evaluating like this type of work I want
to do or these are people I want to work
work with this is going to is this gonna
set up my next jump right because your
first your first job is important we
have bills to pay you have skills the
develop I get that but like really
you're trying to think about like what
is this sort of a pathway to and so
remember as you're evaluating that like
this is a really really crucial step for
you and to interview them as much as
they're interviewing you whether that's
through kora or working on an
open-source project or whatever they
might be yeah I think that there's a
nice round answer because it's not just
about positioning yourself to that
company and finding a company that's
that's a 50 it's really more about
finding a company that's a fit to you
and and your the rest of what follows
and applying for that job or
interviewing for that job or actually
working on that job will actually come a
lot more easily and you'll be a lot
happier and I think also be a lot more
confident thank you for all of all of
that it was awesome so I a very quick
one superhero pose so this was a very
popular TED talk a few years ago and
that you could increase confidence by
standing up and forming the superhero
pose so I would like a again up a panel
answer fact or fiction does something
that that you've seen work
so there's a lot of controversy around
that in a scientific community choose
this Amy Cannata has a new paper out
where she kind of gets a lot of support
for this notion I would just say if it
helps you to feel confident in that
moment Who am I to judge if you want to
dance
I listen to heavy metal a lot to get in
the mood so whatever it gets you in the
mood its power posing or listening to to
motor hats use that waiting for Niko to
bring in metal every what's your take
yeah I'm generally skeptical of like
this one silly trick to make you into
Elon Musk but no I think for me it's um
I like do yoga and so when I get
stressed out I go into this like a yoga
breathing and I freak out everyone
because I sound like Darth Vader like
that's my thing
I can explain the physiology of y.d
stresses me but so yeah I think it's
fine something that works for you
whether it's carrying something that
makes you feel grounded or you know
listening to metal or whatever it is I'm
generally skeptical of the
one-size-fits-all
advice for those things yeah I generally
believe find something that sort of
helps you prepare so before whether it's
an interview whether it's getting up on
a panel and talking like find something
that's sort of like centers you and then
always have something where in the
moment where if you forget to say
something or I swear all the time so if
I swear and it gets me help off my game
like something that sort of resets you
and those are two those can be two very
different things but I find having both
of those sort of like set before you
have any sort of like interaction can be
super helpful yeah so superhero pose yes
no I've tried it metal works better
let's do that so I recently read an
article that said some one you know the
global you you should change jobs every
eighteen months so there's some some
wisdom out there that says in order for
you to grow in your career
need to change jobs every 18 months what
are your what are your thoughts on this
is this something that you know actually
makes sense like do you in order for you
to grow in your own skillset is this
something that they you know you have to
actually change what you're doing in
order to make that happen I think there
there are two things one is growing your
skillset and two is growing your salary
and hopefully you're in a place for
those things go together but that's not
always the case I think that you know
having worked as a recruiter and having
been an engineer before that one thing
I've seen that definitely helps you grow
your salary is going out and getting
other offers while you're still working
in fact I think that if you stay at the
same company you know you yearly review
and if you're doing a good job your
salary will sort of slowly grow up
incremental II whereas if you get out
there and you get a bunch of competing
offers and you go to your boss and you
say look you know I'm underpaid by 20 or
30 percent either they will give you
that raise or you'll go to that next job
and then each time you can make these
huge leaps and as you get more senior
you're gonna get more and more equity
which hopefully is gonna be much more
valuable in cash that that's completely
distinct from whether you're getting
better at your job or not and I think
that that's something that individually
you know when you start stagnating
especially early in your career you
probably should leave the minute you
feel like you're stagnating because uh
early in your career is what sets the
tone for the rest of it and you know
generally the younger you are the more
plastic your brain is that's sad but
true I'm definitely worse at programming
now that I was when I was a teenager
so you know just try to optimize for
those things and advocate for yourself
and maybe sometimes it's a matter of
switching teams within an org than
leaving that company is hands-down the
most important thing is learning and
being around the kinds of people that
enable you to learn and push you and
make you better and the minute you feel
like you're the smartest person in the
room you should get the hell out in
terms of growing your income that is
true there studies out there that show
that you gain more of a time if you
change jobs more often I would ship in
something else and I've ever learned
that term recently from a book called
firms of endearment by Raj Sisodia and
he was talking of psychological income
as opposed to monetary income and I
think enjoying what you do and growing
as a person is sometimes something that
you can do when you stay within one
company longer I've been with
Bertelsmann for roughly seven and a half
years right now luckily my my gora my
job has been growing all the time and
there's new initiatives every every
month and every year now we're doing a
lot of stuff with the SEC but there's
other things and other projects that I'm
actually working on for for four or five
years in a row and this is just another
dimension of a job that you will
probably not see if you switch your
employer every eighteen month and so
maybe it's also something to explore at
different phases in your life now you
know I'm married I have kids I have a
house you need a little more stability
so sometimes you want to do something in
one part of your life maybe change early
a little bit often and then find some
some phase where just actually grow as a
person within the company yeah this day
I'll make this quick I don't know the
timeframe is something I would optimize
optimize for I think that's too hard to
predict especially within the context of
like smaller companies I would always
think about it like what is it that you
want to run towards and make sure that
you're consistent Sears consistently
running in that direction sometimes
that's within the company sometimes
that's outside of it and then the
timeframe is sort of secondary to that
fact because what you definitely don't
want to do is just say this is terrible
I'm gonna run away from it because
that's that's a hard sort of wheel to
get stuck in yeah I was just gonna add
is yes I actually agree like you should
quote change jobs every 18 months or so
but I don't confuse your job title
changing with your job changing yes so
I've been at Atlassian for three years
and have had the same job title but
we're a hyper growth company and so my
job has gotten bigger every week that
I'm there right so just just thinking
about that is what does change look like
for you someone might have you know ten
years at one company but they may have
done six different jobs or had
continuously different spans of control
and that counts as a new job as well and
again a lot of it comes down to you
being able to articulate those changes
what skills did you gain or
responsibilities did you get rather than
just focusing on job titles which as we
see people switching careers in domains
are gonna be less and less useful I
don't think I've ever worked at a
company where the titles that people put
on LinkedIn or how anyone refers to
people internally right it's completely
true yeah like titles on LinkedIn are
on and on that prolific note
thank you everybody for joining us and
and and hopefully you learned something
useful in increasing your own confidence
in your career
[Applause]